why don't we start with that england
lifting all legal restrictions on monday
but infection rates are as we've been
discussing
at their highest levels since january
are we doing the right thing do you
think
well i'm not sure uh and
i'm not quite clear as to why
the whole process is being presented as
as you just did
why on earth has it been called freedom
day
mean the reality is that there's a very
nasty
uh pandemic underway which is extremely
active within the uk uh
thanks to brilliant science and really
good work by
the national health service in the uk an
awful lot of british people have been
vaccinated so although there are a lot
of cases
in in the uk per day up in the 40 000
there are mercifully at the moment quite
few deaths
but this is a very rapidly changing
situation it's
thoroughly dangerous and i think
no one at least who's a specialist in
public health
would be wanting to encourage an
attitude by those in authority
that suggests that somehow the problem
is
solved so do you think do you think it's
a reckless thing to do
in the senate i'm never going to use
that sort of language you see
i do agree with the general
statement that humanity is going to have
to work out how to live with this virus
and my reason for saying that is that my
own view
is the virus is going to be around for
quite a long time
there's no sign that it's going to just
disappear
and indeed it has a habit of mutating
and some of the mutants appeared to be
nastier than the original virus
so it's going to be around and it's it
is a nasty virus
if you've got diabetes if you've got
heart disease if you are
my sort of age in the 70s uh if you get
this virus
and you haven't been vaccinated you've
got a high likelihood of being seriously
ill
and even dying so it's not good
well that's the question that's the
question i mean that's the the question
where uh the issue on which i think the
government
and if you believe what they said the
other day the
scientists would differ with you because
they say this link between
the infection and serious illness
and hospitalization and certainly death
they would say
they say that's been severely weakened
are you less sure about that
no it has been weakened and i'm
delighted i mean that's why
the uh the reduction in restrictions
is thinkable in the uk uh the fact is
that the
so it's about 40 000 cases are not
associated with anything like the level
of
severe illness or death that we saw
at the beginning of the year it's a
remarkable improvement
but just hear this mark about 1 in 20
people who get infected
with this virus have a really unpleasant
long illness it can go on for at least
three months perhaps six months
and it's not a trivial illness in some
it's associated with inflammation
of the membrane around your heart in
others it's associated
with problems in your head other people
get long-term difficulties
with moving around with their arms and
legs
several that i know have difficulty with
concentrating they say
that they're sitting and working
normally and suddenly their brain goes
to complete mush
one in 20. now yesterday they were i
think
40 000 people diagnosed positive with
coven in the uk
forty thousand one in twenty of those is
going to end up with long covey well is
that is that right give even if they've
been double vaccinated i mean
that's the point the government's making
that our very high rate of vaccination
is where we are different and the
argument they put
is if not now when because they say if
you leave it and delay then we're into
autumn and we're into winter and all the
other problems that the nhs
will have to deal with yeah so mark i
all i accept all that and i want to go
back and say to you again
that the last thing i would want is
for society to go into
further restrictions i hate it i think
that it
undermines life for so many people
particularly poorer people on low
incomes if they are
asked to stay at home so my approach
to dealing with covid is not to say
oh well as if there's virus around then
we've all got to stop
moving we've all got to stop working no
i'm saying we need to be able to work to
be
able to have fun but at the same time
we need to keep this virus at bay and
not let it get in and to do that
there are two things one is we have to
behave
in ways that make it pretty unlikely for
this virus to spread around
because we're the solution the virus is
the problem
and we are the the force that's going to
deal with it
secondly i think that we really need to
be sure
that public health services are able
to detect people with the disease to
make sure they isolate
to find their contacts and make sure
they isolate those are the two things
that i'm asking every single country in
the world to do
make sure your people know how to
pretend to prevent it and get the public
health right
so you wouldn't then be lifting these
legal
restrictions on social distancing or on
masks in um crowded indoor places and on
public transport you would keep those as
legally backed restrictions would you i
would
but you see i i have been saying to
myself that perhaps there are things
that the british government and their
experts
know that i don't know
and that therefore mean that whatever
comment
i make is just not relevant there must
be some
some extra factor that the uk
has at its disposal to want to
be actually advising people that they
don't need to face mask or distance
well just at a time when we're at about
40 000
cases a day well i mean i've put to you
the arguments that they are putting what
else could it be do you think then that
they know that
don't know that i i mean i'm i'm
i need to go on and and trying to find
out but
where i am in in the border between
france
and switzerland uh i i
talked a lot to the public health people
here and i've obviously
been close to the decisions that are
made
and they are taking the current uh
tendency for increase they've not got
quite as high figures as the uk has got
but they're taking it really seriously
yeah but so
what the government's saying actually
sorry to interrupt you
what the government's saying is that
they're going to leave it now to
individual responsibility
that there's social responsibility and
yeah and and you know they're going to
trust the public in other words
well i'm super keen on that and i've
always said that's what we need to move
towards but
it does help ordinary people like me
and you if those in authority
give us pretty consistent guidance as to
what to do
but if you have a cabinet running a
country
and you've got some in the cabinet
saying well i might wear a mask
sometimes
but i'll make up my mind and see close
to the time
and you've got others going to say well
i'm not going to wear my mask at all i
want to get rid of it
and still a third group who's saying no
i'm going to be very careful cautious
and keep my mask
there's something wrong because either
we've learned
about this virus and how it behaves over
the last 18 months
and we've learned enough to know what
everybody should do
and shouldn't do or there's nothing to
learn
and i would say mark that there's a lot
to learn
and i would expect a government to have
a concerted approach
to what to do and to make sure that
everybody follows that approach whether
it's
legal or non-legal let's at least get
consistency
because humans are great if they're
given
consistent advice but basically if
they're given
inconsistent advice they say well if
those lot don't know what to do
why should i pay any attention to them